on Wednesday a fire left Bernie Sanders
supporter who despised president Trump
opened fire on Republican Congress
people practicing for a bipartisan
charity baseball game now we all know
that if the situation had been reversed
if a president from supporter and Bernie
hater had opened fire on who rational
Democrats we would be treated to be full
spectacle of media faux outrage we get
long-winded stem winders about
Republicans creating a climate of hate
and violence we receive stern talking-to
is about gun culture and polarizing
rhetoric we know this because it's been
a strategic mainstay for Democrats for
half a century going all the way back to
the left blaming the right for a climate
of eight that supposedly led to JFK's
assassination by economy in 1963 the
left is lame talk radio for the Oklahoma
City bombing Sarah Palin in the right
for the attempted assassination of Gabby
Giffords by mentally ill man by the way
Bernie Sanders even attempted to raise
money off that canard Confederate flag
donors for a massacre at a historically
black church and President Trump for a
stabbing in Portland committed by a
Bernie Sanders supporter but is it right
to blame Sanders and leftist ideology
more broadly for Wednesday's shooting no
it isn't OK rhetoric is not directly
responsible for violence almost at
advocate violence radical jihadism
advocates violence the bulk of its
supporters know this and support
violence a solid contingent of its
followers participate in violence the
same is not true for American brand
political weapon ISM as vile as it is
for the right to equate verbiage with
violence no matter how inflammatory the
verbiage is to fall prey to the same
snowflake syndrome the right condemns on
college campuses there is no logical gap
between attempting to blame right-wing
speakers for supposed violent speech in
opposing black lives matter and
attempting to blame Sanders for the sins
of a random follower this leaves two
questions on the table first are we
living through a more toxic political
climate than ever before in American
history promoting individual acts of
violence among the mentally unstable and
second are we in danger of blurring the
lines between passionate rhetoric and
actual advocacy toward violence well as
far as the first question goes the
answer is obviously no it would take
really a lot of ignorance in American
history to believe that our current
political climate is worse than civil
war year America or even late 1960s
America if only because our underlying
problems are significantly less
horrifying yes our political climate is
toxic
just yesterday Virginia Governor Terry
McAuliffe who attempted to blame gun
control for the shooting suggested that
the Trump campaign or someone associated
with it
acted reasonably with regard to Russia
the entire resistance is built on the
rhetoric of a wartime underground by the
same token the right has taken to using
war language far more regularly even
than it did in the Obama era we're told
Vern a civil war that the media are
enemies but here's the truth nobody took
this stuff particularly seriously we can
all tell the differences between
rhetorical flourishes and violent
advocacy except when we can which brings
us to the second question are we moving
beyond purple language and into the
realm of actual violent advocacy on both
left and right the answer seems to be
yes on the left
thanks to politicians attempting to
capitalize on public anger groups like
Antiqua run free in major American
cities acts of violence against Trump
supporters are brushed off or treated by
the media as he said she said situations
on the right too many Republicans ignore
or downplay incidents like the Gregg
June Forte incident in Montana or
then-candidate Trump's talk about people
paying their bills if they assaulted
protesters there two ways to deal with
the problem first we have to establish a
bright-line rule no defending or
advocating violence period end of story
second we should all probably take a
deep breath before we hit Send it's not
our fault if fringe characters take
advantage of our language to do violence
we never suggested and don't support but
let's all do our best and yes I'm
including myself here to use language we
can defend morally but doesn't mean
tamping down our passion with regard to
politics it does mean thinking twice
before hitting Send on a tweet or
Facebook post comparing Republicans to
Isis
thanks to that health care policy or
suggesting that Democrats are eager to
watch Americans die in a fiery incident
in terrorist incident because they
oppose president Trump's travel ban
perhaps the language of civil war is
perfectly appropriate we're willing to
stand by it so be it but let's think it
through this seems like a decent thing
to do if we wish to preserve it some
semblance of a social fabric i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
so in the aftermath of yesterday's
horrific congressional shooting in all
prayers for Steve Scalise the House
Majority Whip who apparently is still in
critical condition was undergoing
surgery all throughout the night and
everybody should take a moment today and
just say a prayer for congressman
Scalise but in the aftermath of that
there have been a bunch of reactions
that are quite fascinating it seems like
we are now on the verge of going too far
in the other direction what I mean by
that is that if we were on the verge of
going too far in the everyone is angry
let's shout at each other and hit each
other with sticks direction now it seems
like we're in danger of going too far
along me everybody just needs to never
say anything that could offend anyone
and I want to be careful about what we
say are the kinds of speech that are
appropriate and talking about people on
the right and the left I want to be
careful and go through what kind of
speech I think are really damaging
dangerous and which kinds of speech are
just typical political rhetoric because
this is the sort of situation where
people could say okay a nutcase went
crazy and shot a bunch of people let's
all get rid of all offensive rhetoric
let's get back to this kind of faux
civility we'll never say anything
inflammatory we'll never say anything
interesting will never use language that
is evocative we all have to check
ourselves all the time at the door I
want to go through it I think there are
three different types of language and I
want to go through those in a second and
discuss which ones are acceptable which
ones are not obviously none of us should
be regulated but which ones are
acceptable and which ones are not in
sort of everyday use because I'm a
little bit frightened but the snowflake
syndrome that now attends to college
campuses being picked up by the right in
response to the less and less always
says people like me speaking on college
campuses well that creates a climate of
violence and people are going to get
hurt so we have to shut down Shapiro I
don't want to see the same thing happen
on the right with regard to people on
the left us saying well you know when
when they say that Trump is an American
or when they say Trump is a tyrant
that's just bad and it gets people
killed I don't want to do that because
again I like having the same moral
standard for everyone's I'm going to
talk about that in just a second but
before I get to that I first want to say
thank you to our advertisers over at
wing so you don't know anything about
wine but you have a dinner party tonight
and you don't know which we're going to
bring this is why you need to go over to
wink calm try wink calm slash magnets
try winc calm slash man what they do is
they have a
quick algorithm you fill it out it tells
you you put in sort of your tastes what
was you like to eat together do you like
meat with certain flavors you like
things that are spicy you like things
that are sweet and then they recommend a
line for you and they send it direct to
your door and right now fry winks calm /
Ben means they'll offer listeners $20
off their first order when you go to try
once calm / bend and their bottles are
13 bucks they start at just 13 bucks
they're high-quality wine made directly
by wink everyone in the office except
for me actually has tried the wine is
why they're all drunken savages but they
all they all drink heavily all the time
but they think that the wine from link
is the best wine so dry wink calm t ry
winc complex Ben get $20 off your first
order and again it helps ensure that
you're getting the right wine for that
dinner party make it look like you know
what the hell you're talking about
when you bring a bottle of wine to
somebody's party try blink calm / then
try wink / then use this black pencil I
know we sent you and also you see get
that $20 off your first your first buy
plus complimentary shipping so very cool
okay so in the aftermath of the attack
yesterday there was this brief moment
where everybody came together and
everybody does this every so often after
Gabby Giffords there was a 48-hour
period where people were nice to each
other after 9/11 there was a probably
four month period where everybody was
really nice to each other yesterday it
was about a six hour period so the
amount of time will nice to each other
after a horrific incident that that
really goes to the heart of America has
now been reduced to less than the amount
of time that it takes for a yoghurt to
spoil if you leave it out of the
refrigerator but yesterday people said
the right things in the immediate
aftermath of the attack here with Bernie
Sanders it was will remember one of his
volunteers who went out and shot
somebody
the shooter was a Sanders supporting
Trump hating leftist maniac and he
specifically targeted congressional
Republicans if there hadn't been heroes
on the ground there - / - in particular
to put this guy down probably 15 to 20
congressmen are dead today here's Bernie
Sanders talking about how horrified he
was to learn there was one of his
volunteers I have just been informed
that the alleged shooter at the
Republican baseball practice this
morning is someone who apparently
volunteered on my president
campaign I am sickened by this
despicable act and let me be as clear as
I can be violence of any kind is
unacceptable in our society and I
condemn this action in the strongest
possible terms real change can only come
about through non-violent action and
anything else runs counter to our most
deeply held American values I know I
speak for the entire country and saying
that my hopes and prayers are that
representative Scalise congressional
staff and the Capitol Police officers
who were wounded make a quick and full
recovery I also want to thank the
Capitol Police for their heroic actions
to prevent further home okay so there's
Bernie Sanders saying exactly the right
thing obviously violent activity needs
to be put aside when talk in a minute
about whether the left is indeed putting
aside violence rhetoric and violent
activity because I think the answer is
in large measure no but Sanders has
actually been pretty consistent on this
point right he was one of the guys who
said that the riots at Berkeley when he
innopolis went to Berkeley he said that
those riots were wrong he said that Ann
Coulter should speak at Berkeley and
shouldn't be shut down so I can't blame
Bernie Sanders per se for this I know a
lot of people are trying to because
Bernie says they're trying to hold
burning it to his own standard back in
Sanders fundraised off of the idea that
Gabby Giffords was shot because Sarah
Palin put some sort of targeting
district map on her on her Facebook page
there was no link whatsoever between
Palin and the shooter Sanders raised
money off of it anyway so if you're
going to hold the left of their own
standards we're going to say that toxic
rhetoric causes incidents like this that
you have to hold Bernie responsible but
I'm not Bernie I thought it was wrong
when Bernie did it and so I'm not going
to be Bernie now and say that it's that
it's Bernie's fault Paul Ryan I thought
had a great response yesterday also
here's what he had to say on the floor
of Congress there are very strong
emotions throughout this house today
we are all horrified by this dreadful
attack on our friends and on our
colleagues and those who serve and
protect this capital we are all praying
for those who are attacked and for their
families Steve Scalise Zachary Barth
Matt Micah special agent David Bailey
special agent Krystal Greiner we are all
giving our thoughts to those currently
being treated for their injuries at this
moment and we are united we are united
in our shock we are united in our
anguish an attack on one of us is an
attack on all of us
okay so Paul Ryan of course saying the
right things is well Nancy Pelosi the
House Minority Leader
she said much the same thing she said
she was praying for Scalise and Trump
and then she of course came out
immediately today because the climate of
toxic political rhetoric in the country
is the fault of Republicans so that
lasted for five entire second now I want
to go through I think some of the some
of the types of speech that are out
there and whether we should hold them
responsible for violence John Nolte I
thought had a really great piece over at
Daily wire today Nolte is a firebrand
for sure and only had a piece today
talking about the case basically that
CNN is responsible for this by CNN's own
standard and that's basically correct
CNN has said over and over and over that
it was it was the Confederate flag that
caused the shooting down that encircle a
black church in Charleston they said
that it was the pizza gate conspiracy to
cause pizza gay guy to go and shoot up a
restaurant they said that it was Sarah
Palin responsible for Gabby Giffords all
of it and then they go out there and
they say that the Shakespeare and the
power of assassination of Trump thing is
awesome
they hire Kathy Griffin and then
reluctantly fire Kathy Griffin they CNN
makes comments all the time about how I
mean they trying to connect Steve
Scalise is congressman
to the KKK yeah all of this is is it
goes to the hypocrisy of the left and I
think that it demonstrates is the left
is rightly getting batted around for
this today it demonstrates the right
not make them say mistake we should not
make the same mistake where we say okay
political rhetoric is connected to
individual actions because the next time
some coupe happens to listen to Rush
Limbaugh at any point and then goes and
shoots somebody the entire left is going
to say well it's Rush Limbaugh's well
you know this guy we shut off the
Congress people he was a big Rachel
Maddow town is that Rachel Maddow is
fault no I don't think that it's Rachel
Maddow is fault so there are three there
there are three sorts of speech that I
think are worthwhile considering and and
I think that we need to be exact in how
we do this because I sort of argued it
vaguely yesterday but I didn't think
that was exact enough so here they're
three types of speech that are worth
considering that's whether they cross a
line or not whether we also think twice
before using them and two of them I
think that they do cross a line and they
are becoming more and more prevalent so
number one speech that actively
advocates violence so it's actually
illegal to tell people go hit that guy
right you're not actually allowed to say
that in the United States but there's
something that sort of borders on it
which is violence is kind of great you
should go do it not like a specific
direction that you should do violence to
ending one person but a generalized
notion that you should go to violence to
people generally Jessie Ben is a
columnist for The Huffington Post and he
wrote that a violent response to Trump
would be quote as logical as any
he wrote that last week in The
Huffington Post he has a he has a
cartoon on the Todd's pinned on top of
his Twitter feed that shows the it shows
Pepe the Frog being literally beheaded
and then there's a swastika on camera so
there is this element of the left that
actually is good with violence and
advocates for violence and makes room
for violence you see it more broadly on
the left when it comes to people like
Maxine Waters who'd said that the LA
riots were in LA uprising or Marilyn
Mosby in Rabbid not Marilyn Mosby DC the
mayor of Baltimore who had said that she
was Stephanie rawlings-blake who had
said that she had made room for rioters
in Baltimore when things went bad or
even President Obama sort of
incentivizing rioters in Ferguson you
know that sort of stuff is really
dangerous and there is a link between
that sort of rhetoric and violence when
aunt Eva pushes actual violence at
Berkeley
we're in that category and yes when
President Trump says or when who's then
candidate Trump when he says he's going
to hit Wiegel those people who punch
other people were in that category that
sort of stuff is dangerous
that sort of stuff is linked to violence
people who actively advocate violence
are part of the problem okay
category number two people who defend
violence so this is slightly bigger okay
this is a bigger group of people very
small group of people who actively
advocate violence then there are people
who defend violence and that is on the
Left everybody at the Middlebury
University administration who said it
was okay for people to assault a protest
to assault a professor at the charles
murray event these are the the mayor of
Berkeley who allows Antipa to run
roughshod through the city and hit
people and assault people and then says
we can't do anything about it it's the
the administrators of at Cal State LA we
told the police to basically stand down
so students could hurt other students
who are trying to hear a lecture that I
was giving it's also true people who are
defending outright Greg Jian Forte the
Montana congressional Kansa are making
light from body-slamming reporter okay
when you defend violence you're part of
the problem you are contributing to a
greater violent a greater violent
climate in the country there's a third
type of rhetoric however that I want to
be very careful about because I think
that we are now in danger of falling
into the snowflake trap which I'll
describe in just a second but before I
get to that and say thank you to our
sponsors over at blanket so you don't
have a lot of time to gather information
I set around reading books all day I
have a career that allows me to do that
most people don't most people you're in
the car you have 15 minutes what sort of
information can you grab outside of the
ben shapiro shows
that's where blinka comes in so blinka
is an app that essentially summarizes
the main point of all these books that
you definitely wanna read which is
awesome because even if you read a 400
page book the amount of takeaway that
you're going to get from that might just
fit into 15 minutes what blinken says
they summarize the key points of books
and then they allow you to take those in
so if you have an hour drive you can
basically read four books in one day
if 2,000 of the best-selling non-fiction
books transformed in these powerful
packs but they call blinks you can read
or listen to in just 15 minutes
books like why nations fail 500 page
book great book I've read the entire
book but do I remember more than 15
minutes of content from it probably not
blink as you go there and you listen to
the summary of the book and suddenly you
know as much about that book as I
probably do even though I actually sat
there for hours and hours reading the
book and this is true for a wide variety
of books and it's got fields ranging
from productivity to business
science history to self-improvement
fantastic fantastic app I love it it's
blankets BL i NK is T Bo I NK is t.com /
been if you want to go over there right
now and you go to blink is calm / been
and that allows you to get a three month
period for free when you get a yearly
subscription or a free trial period
right now so you can give it a listen
you get that free trial or three months
off your yearly plan when you join
today's blinka comm / been awesome
service I use it myself
very cool okay so I've discussed the
first two types of rhetoric that I think
are off-limits or should be off-limits
that doesn't mean legal but it does mean
that people of good conscience should
not use them then there is the third
group and this is where I see the right
starting to make a mistake there's this
third part of speech where people on the
right are beginning to veer off into
snowflake land and I'll give you an
example so representative Jack Burkman
Republican he comes out he blames the
media he was at this shooting he blamed
the media for complicity in the attack
here's what he had to say do you agree
with that do you think that's that the
hateful rhetoric has gotten just high no
I agree
yeah I agree with I agree with Rodney
wholeheartedly and that the hateful
rhetoric serves no positive purpose in
fact today and obviously serves a
negative purpose but unfortunately and
I'm look at all the media in the eye
when I say this friendships and cordial
relationships don't make good news so I
can tell you especially as the president
of the freshman class Republicans we are
united along with our Democratic
freshman counterparts to bring civility
back to the 115 Congress okay okay
that's all wonderful that's all good but
the idea the media to blame here I think
is over the top and I'll explain why I
take Eric Bolling on Fox News who's used
some colorful language in his time he
said sort of the same thing he said how
many innocents have to die before we
realize that words matter spill blood
guy really ma'am soup dogs gun Kathy
Griffin's head
Shakespeare's bloody rampage it goes on
and on how many innocent people have to
die before we realize that words do
matter
crazy people act on the crazy things
they hear from Paula
issues and celebrities think before you
utter those blind hateful words next
time liberals because there are crazy
people out there taking your metaphors
literally for liberals blow a gasket
saying I'm being partisan I will tell
you I will guarantee you this I would be
writing the same monologue and
delivering the same monologue if it were
a Democrat softball practice targeted
and terrorized that I promise you okay
maybe maybe not mark Stein says sort of
the same thing he says the big problem
here is lesson once did he humanize
their political opponents the left wants
to denormalize and dehumanize to use
your words it's political opposition and
they do that in a variety of ways so for
example when charles murray wants to
give a speech at Middlebury College they
have to have a riot they don't have a
debate in which they demolish his
argument they don't want to win the
debate they want to prevent the debate
taking place okay and I think that
that's a good example but where I see
this going off the rails I don't think
bowling or Stein say anything deeply
wrong there in the examples they use are
from the first two categories of speech
but what I do see is a lot of people
today saying things like well you know
the resistance ankles are colonization's
the resistance finally goes live fire
okay we called ourselves the Tea Party
the Tea Party if you recall was actually
a resistance movement to the government
okay that didn't was not averse to using
it was not averse to using violence back
in the net and the Tea Party ended up
becoming the American Revolution the
idea that if you use rhetoric that is
charged that this is the same thing as
using rhetoric that defends violence or
advocates violence I think it is a
dangerous precedent that we are setting
and I can see it being flipped very very
easily I don't see in an a problem with
saying that a president is acting
tyrannical I don't think that's calling
for the president to be assassinated I
don't think the vast majority of
Americans think that's calling for the
president to be assassinated
when people call themselves the Tea
Party or the resistance I don't think
just because you say you're a member of
the resistance that means that you're
like a member of the French Resistance
and you're going to go out there and
start shooting Republicans you know when
when people who are pro-life talk about
the killing of babies in the womb I
don't think that that's an implicit call
to murder abortionists I don't and the
vast majority of pro-life people I mean
virtually all of them know that right
and the
thing is true on the left when they say
that on the left that Republicans want
to kill granny that they're the
murderers and like Isis because of
trumps health care plan so I think
that's stupid yeah I think it's
ridiculous in stupid do I also think
that it's causing violence not really I
mean it you know when I wrote the book
Oli's which the New York Times
bestseller and bullies is all about the
let's attempt to demonize us to attack
us on a character level for our
political views and I said this is
morally wrong it is morally wrong but it
is not necessarily connected with
violence so the left is constantly
attempting to say everybody's a racist
sexist pig and homophobe that doesn't
necessarily mean but they want everybody
to be killed and well I say I objected
the language on the ground that you
should have evidence for the assertions
that you put forth I think there's a
bigger risk right now than the climate
like this people are going to
immediately start saying well you're not
allowed to say charged things because
you say charged things that means some
crazy is going to go up if we judge the
value of political rhetoric by the crazy
who goes off there's not going to be a
lot of political rhetoric left if we're
going to play this game where some
nutcase shoots up congressional staffers
and shoots up a congressman and he
watches Rachel Maddow so we blame Rachel
Maddow then we can't be surprised when
the left turns around they already do
this because they're because they're
awful we can't be surprised when the
left turns around and says well it's
Sean Hannity's fault if somebody goes
nuts and shoots up a Democratic Congress
office you know the left does it anyway
so I understand the temptation is
turnabout is fair play temptation that
doesn't mean that it's right so I think
that we have to be careful about this
routine now on that last point as far as
immunization and demonizing your
political opposition last point here I
think that's a gray area so I think some
demonization is okay some demonization
is not okay
some demonization is sort of acceptable
what is not acceptable is demonization
combined with defensive violence or
advocacy of violence so if you demonize
your political opponent then you say oh
yeah and by the way if you punch
somebody in the face that's okay right
if you say my opponents a Nazi I think
that's basically you may be wrong you
may be stupid what you're saying may be
dumb but I don't think that it's linked
to violence you say my opponent isn't
not the and it's okay to punch not these
I think that you start to get into
really morally dicey territory so I want
to make those distinctions because I
don't want a standard set whereby
anything political anybody says we're
going to now judge the value of that
Paula
based on the outlier who is vulnerable
to suggestion and then goes out and
shoots people I just think that's a
dangerous thing okay well as we continue
here on the bench Shapiro show we're
going to be talking about President
Trump and what he says is a witch-hunt
against him this obstruction of justice
news Washington Post breaks last night
that robert muller who is the the
special counsel is now investigating
Trump for obstruction of justice we'll
talk about that what it means why it's
happening and why Trump is actually kind
of right on this one we'll talk about
that but you have to subscribe over a
Daily wire for that so for $8 a month
you too can get a subscription over at
Daly wire.com that means that you can be
also be part of the mailbag tomorrow
we're going to be doing the mailbag live
and my dad's going to be in studio so
we're going to be talking about
everything father and son related if you
have questions for my father then
definitely write those in we'll ask them
to him during the mailbag segment of the
of the show let's go on an annual
subscription right now the an annual
subscription you get a free signed copy
of the book that I wrote with my dad say
it so all that fathers and sons and
baseball great Father's Day gift even it
comes a little bit late a great belated
Father's Day gift terrific book if I do
say so myself and you get that free sign
when you get an annual subscription so
go over and check it out you wanna
listen later go to iTunes or SoundCloud
and make sure that you leave us a review
and subscribe we always appreciate it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the largest
conservative podcast in the country
[Music]